forget everything you've heard about the
endometriosis diet i'm here to tell you
the truth hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be chatting the truth about
the food rules that influencers love to
dole out for endometriosis but first let
me tell you about my sponsor build bar
if you have yet to try my go-to favorite
protein bar get on it i don't know about
you guys but i hate most protein bars on
the market because they're just kind of
chalky and gritty but build bars have a
texture kind of like nougat or like a
thick marshmallow and it's coated in
actual chocolate so because your girl is
having a rough day here today's flavor
is my favorite cookie dough chunk hello
never gets old never
oh yeah
oh
you can see those little pieces joe
[Music]
15 grams of protein and they are a lower
sugar bar so if you want to build into a
hunger crushing combo i love to pair
mine with like oatmeal or toast or fruit
so good so if you want to check out
built bars for yourself hit up the link
in the description and use my promo code
abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your order
and you can pause the screen or look in
the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that sub button and follow me on tik tok
and instagram abby's kitchen alright so
endo friends tell me all the time that
they are easily roped in by snake oil
because the wellness industry just loves
to prey on folks in chronic pain but if
you don't already know endometriosis is
a chronic estrogen dependent
inflammatory condition affecting one in
nine women of reproductive age basically
the endometrial tissue starts to grow
outside the uterus which results in
painful periods painful sex painful
bowel movements and urination as well as
heavy periods fatigue ibs symptoms
infertility and increased risk of
ovarian cancer now because of its
hormonal and inflammatory origin a lot
of the foods commonly demonized in the
wellness community for folks with
endometriosis are those that are thought
to be pro-inflammatory
those that dysregulate hormones like
estrogen or those that just exacerbate
digestive symptoms and pain but i spoke
to some of my colleagues who
specifically work in endometriosis to
get the real facts straight so let's
start with the common foods that you've
been told to avoid and what the research
actually says first up fried foods now
most diets on my radar discourage ultra
processed fried foods and in the case of
endometriosis the rationale is to reduce
the consumption of trans fats which
prospective research has associated with
endometriosis risk now while trans fats
were banned in north america in 2018
they are still found in highly processed
fried foods because the high cooking
temperature slightly increases the trans
fat content of oil as does cooling and
reheating the same oil so choosing foods
that are grilled baked poached or
roasted instead of fried more often may
help and of course we also want to be
mindful of consuming a lot of packaged
snacks with the words partially
hydrogenated oils which is essentially
code for small amounts of trans fats now
you guys know i am not one to suggest
cutting out foods but trans fats are
basically one of the only food
components we definitively know are not
great for our health even in moderate
amounts next is red meat now this is
another not so shocking recommendation
but red meats are believed to play a
role in endometriosis due to their
saturated fat natural steroid hormone
content or the cooking methods used
which increases advanced glycation end
products one fairly large study did see
an association with frequent consumption
of red meat though other studies have
kind of muddled the waters by finding no
increased risk but a more recent
prospect of study on over 80 000 women
found that women who consumed more than
two servings of red meat daily had a 56
higher risk of endometriosis and
specifically had more pelvic pain they
did not find that poultry fish seafood
or eggs to have the same effect so
focusing on protein intake with those
options plus of course some plant-based
proteins may be a supportive swap next
is another heavy hitter on the foods
with a bad pr list gluten but this time
it may actually be somewhat
evidence-based now one study looked at
over 200 women with endometriosis and
found that a gluten-free diet
significantly reduced pelvic pain pain
during sex and period pain other
research found that patients who avoided
wheat products have better pain scores
and subjective well-being scores than
those who don't now we don't know for
sure why this is but it's possible that
less gluten means fewer ultra-processed
foods or fewer fodmaps which explains
why a lot of my colleagues find that
switching to less refined whole grains
may actually be more effective than
completely cutting them out but that
brings me to the next diet
recommendation low fodmap now some
endometriosis symptoms like abdominal
pain constipation nausea bloating and
diarrhea often cause women to be
misdiagnosed with ibs before finally
getting a proper endo diagnosis still
there does seem to be some overlap in
these conditions and those with ibs
symptoms do report feeling better on a
modified or low fodmap diet note that
the low fodmap diet is not really like
one diet each person will have their own
unique fodmap triggers so always work at
the gi dietitian on a proper fodmap
elimination and trial and you can check
out my own fodmap experience in my video
right here next let's talk about alcohol
so what we know is that alcohol raises
estrogen levels which then thickens the
endometrium and this ultimately results
in more painful endo symptoms one review
of the literature found an association
between alcohol use and endometriosis
with one study finding that 50 of women
reported adverse effects when they drink
does that mean you need to maintain
absolute abstinence well while a
meta-analysis did conclude that any
amount of alcohol seemed to increase
risk other research has found no link at
all so while it doesn't seem like
alcohol causes endo i think it's worth
experimenting to see if having an
occasional celebratory drink or weekend
glass of wine exacerbates a flare for
you you can work out the unique risk
benefit analysis for yourself now like
alcohol caffeine also increases estrogen
levels in some populations which seem to
actually be race dependent but of course
this has resulted in a universal
recommendation in the endo community to
limit the morning joe got you a
cappuccino with three red bulls and
while some research has found an
association with coffee intake and
endometriosis diagnosis others don't
seem to find any strong association at
all of course because of the association
between gi or ibs symptoms and endo some
folks may find it triggers a flare so
again we want to experiment to determine
your unique tolerance to caffeine
products and to find an amount if any
that works for you okay so we got
through the not so great news but i
really want to focus our attention on
what we can add to the diet and the good
news is that there's an abundance of
food that may help to support symptoms
and reduce risk now since endometriosis
is considered an inflammatory condition
the general recommendations are all
really going to focus on foods that have
those anti-inflammatory properties most
notably fruits and veg i think most
diets are going to recommend more fruits
and vegetables for really a wide range
of reasons and in the case of
endometriosis the fiber here seems to
reduce estrogen levels while the
antioxidant levels seem to decrease
oxidative stress and other markers of
inflammation most of the research has
found associations between a diet rich
in fruits and vegetables and a reduced
endo risk but specific veggies may
potentially exacerbate symptoms likely
related to fodmap content so this is
where the recommendations can feel a
little bit contradictory and maybe
overwhelming because as we already
discussed
some folks with endo will find that a
gluten-free diet may be best but at the
same time we need to balance this
recommendation with the fiber benefits
of whole grains so again as always work
with a dietitian to determine which
sources of fodmaps and which sources of
fiber are best tolerated for you and
which help to actually help to reduce
symptoms and pain and speaking of
complicated nutrition iron is another
more sticky topic in the endo community
so old-school endometriosis thinking
related to the retrograde menstruation
theory was concerned with evidence on
iron overload in the pelvic cavity which
is thought to play a role in
endometriosis and symptoms but newer
research and clinical observation is
much more concerned with the increased
risk of iron deficiency anemia because
of the heavy periods associated with the
disorder now throw in the positive
association with red meat consumption
and endo which is really like our best
most bioavailable source of iron and
it's honestly confusing as
what we know here is that iron can have
a significant impact on endometriosis
cell gene expression so maintaining
healthy iron levels may help to reduce
symptoms so step one is to have your
iron levels checked regularly by your
doctor to make sure they are within
healthy range and if you're looking low
to focus on non-red meat sources of iron
so that could be fish seafood poultry
and eggs for your hem-based iron or
things like tofu beans nuts seeds and
greens for your non-heme iron ideally
pairing those with some vitamin c rich
fruits and vegetables to improve
absorption and speaking of fish an extra
benefit of including more seafood in our
diet is their anti-inflammatory omega-3
content so research suggests that higher
amounts of epa omega-3s which are found
in salmon tuna mackerel sardines and
algae is linked to less severe symptoms
and pelvic pain likely due to its impact
on prostaglandins so if you enjoy fish
this is a great anti-inflammatory staple
to swap in for protein and iron and if
you don't eat fish an algae-based
supplement may also help now another
controversial and confusing food out
there that is often demonized in some
endo circles is soy and soy based
products now you will absolutely find
influencers out there insisting that you
need to cut out soy since soy contains
compounds called phytoestrogens which
essentially can mimic estrogen in the
body and again since endometriosis is a
hormonal condition this is deemed a
risky choice but while one study found
women who were fed soy formula as kids
had double the risk of endometriosis as
those who didn't the vast majority of
research has actually found it to have a
beneficial impact one study found soy
was not associated with risk of
endometriosis while others have found
that it may actually help to decrease
symptoms now the super simplified
explanation for this very complicated
phenomenon is that phytoestrogens are
weaker than estrogen and when they bind
the estrogen receptors it leaves fewer
spots available for the og estrogen to
bind and this results in a lower
estrogenic effect which may help to down
regulate some of the estrogen-dependent
symptoms in fact one phytoestrogen
called purarin is currently being
investigated as a potential
endometriosis treatment having said that
again this is an individualized thing
since soy contains fodmaps and some
folks symptoms may therefore be
triggered so experiment to see if you
feel better with or without it in the
mix finally let's talk dairy i know
wellness culture usually likes on dairy
but one prospective study found that
both intakes of total and low-fat dairy
independently were associated with a
lower risk of endometriosis women who
are consuming more than three servings
of total dairy per day were 18
less likely to be diagnosed with
endometriosis than those consuming two
or less a meta-analysis confirmed this
suggesting that women consuming three
servings or more had a reduced risk
particularly with higher fat dairy and
cheese but not with butter so ideally we
want to look for vitamin d fortified
dairy since as we'll discuss in a moment
vitamin d deficiency may also put one at
greater risk and to round out this
discussion let's talk supplements again
the focus of the limited research to
date has been on antioxidant based
supplements to counter the chronic
inflammatory condition we know through
correlational research that women with
endometriosis
tend to have lower intakes of
antioxidants like vitamins a c e zinc
and copper than women without one study
testing the impact of supplementation
found that women taking 1200 iu's of
vitamin e and a thousand ius of vitamin
c had a reduction in chronic pain pain
during menstruation and pain during sex
there was also a decline in quantifiable
inflammatory markers compared to the
placebo group we also have early
research on the antioxidant rich
compound curcumin from turmeric which
found that supplementing helped to
suppress the proliferation of
endometrial cells by reducing the
hormone estradiol finally prospective
data suggests that women with the
highest levels of vitamin d have 24
lower risk of endometriosis than women
with the lowest levels so it is possible
that vitamin d may be supportive as well
so to summarize the diet recommendations
for endometriosis are really not
surprising
i mean i'm shocked we're dealing with a
chronic inflammatory condition so a diet
that's rich in anti-inflammatory
compounds like you know antioxidants and
omega-3s and low-in pro-inflammatory
compounds like trans fats seems to be
the most supportive also like all diets
this appears to be highly individualized
so what works for one person might not
have much an effect for another and vice
versa so as always definitely speak to a
dietitian about your unique case and on
that note that's all that i have for you
guys today thank you again to buildbar
for sponsoring if you like this video be
sure to give it that thumbs up leave me
a comment below on what you'd like to
see me discuss next subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]